die cayman s jungs herzlich willkommen
sein video leute mag es heute mit dem
start und das heutige video leute dreht
sich mal eine sache über die man einfach
reden muss die actionserie kammacher zu
dingen die teilweise bisschen seltsam
sind gefallen euch schon mal sehr gut
deswegen kommen doch die nächste weil
das geht ab das geht da was geht da ab
ich glaube gar nicht darum sollte es
geht in diesem video um die cfd trading
einige vielleicht kennt ihr bestimmt man
selbst schon bekommen das ist dieses
rolex nachgeht wie ist einfach die
absolute hört dass wir als gruppe und
damit beschäftigen das heißt bis hin
wird sagen wir schauen uns erst mal das
original zu sein das ist schon eine
komplette doku von störungen schauen wir
auch peter mal rein dem ist nämlich sehr
gut aufgearbeitet meisten los ist nicht
wirklich eine betrugsmasche aber sie
stürzen halt die leute die sich da
relativ blauäugig rhein gegeben in ja
eine problematische situation weil es
einfach riskant ist dazu handeln sie
kriegen hat geld dafür dass leute sie
anwenden wir schauen jetzt mal rein
danach erklärt nicht ganz kurz was
eigentlich cfd ist welche richtung
studiert deswegen keine erklären okay
wir sehen hier am anfang einen jungen
mann in einer alten c klasse vielleicht
einem älteren mercedes audi generation
und eine rolex richtig sehe
was aber was will man mehr
videobearbeitung die kann wahrscheinlich
auch in der gruppe bekommen macht doch
viel hatte ich habe ganz gut ausgesehen
als 1000 euro auf 10.000 euro uhr
ich habe den letzten neun monaten 50.000
euro übernehmen wenn wir was hast du
denn gegessen der ganze 60.000 euro für
ordnung wir mal durch seite neun monate
65.000 euro verdient dann muss man in
deutschland ja noch steuern ein aber bei
der gruppe ist es nicht schön sein aber
perfekt müsste man schon zahlen auf
65.000 euro hätte man am ende vielleicht
so 45.000 euro davon übrig das heißt er
kann sich sein
er hat eigentlich nur 45.000 aber
kaufzusagen für 60.000 beste leben
[Musik]
ja ich muss nie wieder arbeiten
gestern seine 45.000 euro verdient hat
die sachen für 60.000 jobs also das was
ich am 50.000 euro schön
august dann nie wieder arbeiten in
deinem leben perfekt aber es sieht so
aus als hätten sich am kleiderschrank
von seinem papa also wenn du mich fragst
dich
hör auf zu reden er muss nie wieder
arbeiten stellen genau es geht dabei
unsere ortsgruppe mattem ihren stand
sollen und dann passierte was aber die
frage ist worum geht's zeigen was machen
wir diese gruppe es geht um cfd-trading
cfd ist englisch und steht für contract
for difference is was es eigentlich ist
es ein relativ komplizierten
finanzprodukt was schwierig zu
durchschauen ist und es ist sehr riskant
man kann sehr viel geld verlieren und es
ist deutlich riskanter als einfach eine
aktie zu kaufen und es geht bei der
gruppe quasi darum leute dazu zu bringen
mit summen riskanten produkt zu handeln
was der sinn dahinter eigentlich schon
gesehen leute jetzt kommen wir zu dem
zweiten clip das ist der fakt oberhammer
pass auf das ist auch der clip der
abfälle
umlauf in sich trägt manchmal vor dem
video denken einfach jedes mal so ich
will die gruppe porsche cayman s jungs
update irgendwie wieder aus was man sagt
immer so heute morgen hatte ich durst
und jetzt habe ich einen blick
ich kann nur eins sagen ich bin
unglaublich begeistert
man kann es einfach nur jedem empfehlen
das ist schon ein bisschen kritisch
also es ist auf jeden fall schon ein
bisschen gefährlich dass du darzustellen
sollte motto jungen du wirst damit
sofort reich und jeder kann es schaffen
aber es gehört jeder automat steht desto
geringer ist das risiko dass man geld
verliert so ist es auf dem kanal von
trading quatsch oder rainald das video
das die sache gibt schon eine weile die
werbungen diese art von produkt erworben
wird
die gruppe habe ich zurück weil ihr
alter schwede aber ich will das auch gar
nicht richtig sei diese werbeform mal
der anfang ist eigentlich in der kinder
da ist alles vorbei
dabei haben wir so zum red
bei mir läuft nicht bei ihm rennen die
leute in die gruppe dürfte bei nikolov
mit hannover für euch gehabt dass bei
nico läuft falsch es rennt verdammte
kacke das ding ist die seen hat vor
allem einfach alle aus wie leute die
selbst auf sich selbst rein fällen
würden die vergessen so dass dieses
video gemacht haben es war ja später
kommen wie sorgt youtube hat sich so
selbst privat ich muss in die gruppe was
auf krasse ist man hört bei allen seinen
schwäbischen akzent draußen hat
wahrscheinlich jemand einfach so seine
kumpels gehoben hat gesagt ja auch
bewerbung mit mir und sagt sich vor
autos geraten ließ steuerung den
freundlichen art geantwortet weil ich
wünsche dir einen schönen montag ich
schicke dir nachher ein paar infos dann
können wir starten jetzt steht da noch
mehr wenn du mit traden willst melde
dich einfach hier an 24 option dot com
aha guck mal mann eröffnet hier ein
konto bei 24 option mit solchen
geschäften 36.000 euro verloren in
dieser doku 7 das ist bei dieser gruppe
darum geht sich in einem auf der
plattform anzumelden wo es um trading
geht eben und wo wahrscheinlich der der
einfache mittel dann eine provision
bekommt ich glaube der doubs sagen sie
dass derjenige der jemanden für für
solche seite irgendwie 200 euro bonus
bekommt oder so die besucher auf den
führen sind von einer dieser firmen und
finden dort einfach nicht ganz kurzer
ärztlicher part leute weil es wirklich
riskant wollte mal gesagt haben aber
jetzt weiter zum spaßigen youtube kacke
si
schon realistisch dass er irgendwas muss
kurz mal nachrechnen leute wir haben
ich habe mich über 16.000 660 jahre das
kirche war fast gedrittelt wird ja leute
was soll man dazu sagen ich würde sagen
wenn hier innerhalb von drei tagen ein
komplettes erspartes verlieren wollen
schreibt einfach in der nacht dann diese
nummern ja